ladies and gentlemen please Nobel
laureates in physics and chemistry
laureates in Economic Sciences your
excellencies members of the Academy
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences I wish
you all welcome to the 2018 Nobel
lectures in physics and chemistry and
the lecture of the Swedish Riksbank
prize in Economic Sciences in memory of
Alfred Nobel Alfred Nobel was a truly
cosmopolitan and multi-link and he was
multilingual he was fluent in six
languages and the foresight of Alfred
Nobel to establish five prizes for
important achievements with special
instructions in his will that they shall
not be restricted geographically
reflects his international life and
mentality science is indeed an
international endeavor because the
natural laws of the universe are
universal we can all learn and benefit
from fundamental discoveries made by
other humans across the globe in two
days from now we will commemorate Alfred
Nobel's
exceptional generosity and his wish to
make this world a better place the
anniversary of his death that took place
on December 10 1896 is marked by the
Nobel Prize ceremony the Nobel Prizes
have been awarded since 1901 as a
biologist I have to confess that I
regret that Alfred Nobel did not devote
a prize to the field of biology but this
year I can nevertheless rejoice over the
great impact that the discoverer is
rewarded in physics and chemistry have
had on biology and medicine all branches
of science ultimately abide by the same
laws
nature and are more often intimately
interwoven with one another than we
realize
given the international generality of
the sciences the political and religious
efforts in some regions of our planet to
try to restrict the freedom of
researchers who strive for the truth and
to stifle unwelcome facts about a planet
or ourselves is a course of deep concern
to all of us this would surely have
worried Alfred Nobel tremendously but
today let us instead enjoy the fruits of
knowledge the joy of discovery ingenuity
of inventions and improvements and the
many resulting benefits to humankind we
will hear about the power of light both
to grasp and to cut with exquisite
precision and chemical techniques that
use the mechanisms of life to generate
knowledge about cells and proteins
leading to production all of the
pharmaceuticals and we will hear about
studies of the complex relationships
between resources and economy in our
societies and also incorporating climate
this year we even have an even
anniversary this is the 50th time the
Swedish Riksbank prize in Economic
Sciences in memory of Alfred Nobel will
be awarded the the two economy laureates
who will speak later today have
addressed problems of global magnitude
that would undoubtedly have been a
greatest interest to Alfred Nobel so we
can look forward to a very interesting
and educational and inspiring suite of
lectures today so with that I in now
invite my colleague in the Academy of
Sciences professor olga bottner who is
the chairperson of the nobel committee
of physics to introduce the laureates in
physics so once again welcome everybody
to a journey through outstanding
achievements
[Applause]
over the past six decades lasers and
laser based devices have become
indispensable in many areas of society
with its long range narrow beam that can
be focused into a tiny spot a laser
provides high power of a small area and
this is of course useful for cutting
drilling welding but not only that it's
also useful for laser surgery and laser
skin treatment the laser is truly one of
the many examples of how so-called blue
sky discovery in fundamental science
eventually may transform our daily lives
the Nobel Prize in Physics for 2018 has
been awarded for groundbreaking
inventions in the field of laser physics
- Arthur Ashkan sure ha ha whoo ha and
Donna Strickland and all these three
will be giving talks unfortunately dr.
Ashton will be giving a tour by proxy
but nevertheless sends a greeting Ashkan
is an American physicist born in
September 1922 in Brooklyn New York as
an undergraduate at Columbia during the
second world war he worked part time at
the Columbia radiation lab building
magnetrons for the US military raider
systems
receiving a BA in 1947 Ashkan moved to
Cornell here he studied nuclear physics
for doctoral degree deciding in the end
not to pursue a career in this field
where his older brother Julius already
was a renowned scientist participating
in the Manhattan Project obtaining a PhD
in 1952 from Cornell University Ashkan
got an invitation from his former
supervisor at Columbia said Millman to
join the Bell Labs and started working
there researching microwaves before
switching to lasers he was the head of
department of laser science at Bell Labs
home doe for over 20 years from 1963 to
1987 from time to time also filling in
as a member of the technical staff ash
Keens dream was to trap and manipulate
atoms and in 1986 he and his colleague
Steven Chu Nobel laureate 1997
demonstrated the first stable optical
atom trap later known as optical
tweezers Ashkan then focused on
developing the tweezers to capture and
study living things like bacteria algae
red blood cells without harming them his
success has a huge impact on biological
research allowing for instance to study
how infectious organisms attack healthy
cells although still active
unfortunately as I said before dr.
Ashkan cannot be with us today
he sends a greeting though and a close
associate dr. Anita s young boy who will
give the talk in his stead and so I
invite dr. EC envoy to join me on stage
[Applause]
but any I marvel Ashkan I want to thank
the Royal Academy of Sciences for the
great honour of a Nobel Prize and you
know I can't be here for the when the
time comes but my friend Renee who's a
fellow Bell Labs man very good friend
he's going to deliver the lecture in my
place and well okay I hope you enjoy it
thank you
[Applause]
so it is a great pleasure to be here
today to deliver the 2018 physics Nobel
Prize lecture about you asking as you
just saw on the video we prepared the
presentation together and it reflects
what you wanted to discuss today so this
lecture is on optical tweezers and the
application to biological systems first
I will present a few historical events
that shows that our art was interested
by the action of light from a very young
age then I will talk about the early
days of optical trapping light pressure
the original laser trapping optical
levitation and then I will discuss the
work that was recognized by the Nobel
Committee optical tweezers these are
trapping of biological particles and
then biological application of optical
tweezers in 1932 art was ten years old
and he was fascinated by the Crookes
radiometer so a crook try the metre is
it looks like this it's a four veins
that are linked together and suspended
on the pinwheel each of the veins have a
dark side a black side and the other
side is highly reflective I like to act
as a mirror and all of that is within
the glass bulb with partial vacuum so
when light shines on a corridor meter
the black side start to move away from
the light so it starts to move in this
clockwise direction here
so the Crookes radiometer
is moving due to thermal effects in 1944
when art was
22 years old I'm 22 years old he was
working on the past magnetron like was
mentioned earlier it was at Columbia
radiation lab so he decided one day to
shine this magnetron to the diaphragm of
a phone earpiece and my h1 was operating
at 1 kilohertz and he saw a one kilowatt
trace from the COS code at the time he
thought it could be radiation pressure
it in 1966 a few years after the laser
was invented and demonstrated art went
to a conference in Phoenix Arizona where
he saw a video by Rossum and in the
video you would see the particle inside
the laser in the internal beam of the
laser to start to move in straight line
and bounce around and at the time the
auto artists run sunny in May suggested
that it could be a few different things
one was light pressure
the other one was thermal effects so art
calculated what the light pressure will
do and figured out that it could not be
a light pressure so after a few months
everybody settled to say that it is
thermal effect but the main impact of
this video on art is to reignite his
interest in light pressure
so what is like pressure so let's
consider two different type of objects a
metallic mirror that is a highly
reflective and a transparent small
sphere so when a photon comes and hit
the mirror if it's a tiny mirror is
going to start to move in the opposite
direction to conserve the momentum as
the photon has been reflected and the
mirror goes in the other reflection
direction for a power 1 watt this
corresponds to a force of 10 minus 8
Newton which may appear extremely small
but let's look at the transparent sphere
that is one micron in diameter so it's
very small so if we shine light on it
let's say we have a photon that arrived
at the upper part is deflected downwards
and the sphere we start to move upwards
in in reaction to the photon changing
its direction so that the momentum is
conserved if the photon arrived in the
lower part of the sphere it deflected
upward and the sphere goes downwards so
this is the basic mechanism for this
trapping if you have two photons going
symmetrically located the small sphere
would go forward for a power of 1 watt
on the 1 micros micron sphere the
acceleration can induce on the sphere is
on the order of 100,000 times the force
of gravity so the radiation pressure
that appear to be very small on a very
small object like a transparent sphere
can be you can produce tremendous
accelerations
so now let's consider what happened if
the sphere is not exactly on the axis of
the laser as it was in the previous
slide but now is 1/2 axis so what will
happen to that sphere the transparent
sphere so the laser as of course higher
intensity near the center and the reason
goes in a direction and low intensity at
the edges so as we saw in the previous
animation if a photon arrived and the
upper part of the sphere it's good it
will be deflected and it will be a force
for on the sphere if the photon arrived
at the lower part the force in the other
direction on the sphere so that the sum
of the force can be decomposed into two
forces the scattering force which make
the sphere move in the direction of the
beam a gradient force that makes the
sphere goes toward the center of the
beam so what is very interesting here is
that the sphere will be attracted to the
high power region of the laser which
seems a little bit counterintuitive but
it actually happens so the sphere goes
towards the center of the beam so let's
look at a little animation so the
photons are arriving here more photon at
the top because it's near the center
look more or less photon here and the
ball will start to move toward the
center of the beam when it's at the
center it just moved forward to the
scattering force and here it's going to
hit a slide but a microscope slide let's
stop the sphere so this sphere is
trapped like the beam on the left and by
the microscope slide on the right so art
got the idea that because he saw this
phenomenon that he could actually put
two beams counter-propagating and put a
sphere in the middle the transparent
sphere and this fear would be trapped
because the scattering force of this
beam and the scratches form of this beam
would be a comfortable compensate each
other and the particle will be in
equilibrium there so that's part of his
notebook
in 1969 and this notebook was signed by
every deepen and Peter wolf to a famous
scientist on their own and assigned by
Archer Ashton on September 8th so here's
a little animation on this two beam trap
so all the photon arrives symmetrically
so the net force on the sphere is zero
it doesn't move so this is the first all
optical trap so art decided in the next
year and 71 to look at what will happen
if it takes the laser and turn it
upwards and use gravity as a force to to
to produce the trapping so here's the
laser so initially the sphere is sitting
on microscope slide then we turn on the
laser but it's too low power this fear
is not levitating we increase the power
more photons and this fear will start to
levitate and eventually this at the
height that it is determined by the
laser power and the beam divergence
so I decided that he will try to measure
the charge of the electron using an
optical live data so here's the set up
that was in 1980 so there is a sphere
that is levitating and there is a
feedback control where he's monitoring
the height of that sphere and it changes
the power of the laser to keep the
height the same so then he shined UV
light in the chamber that created
electrons and he applied difference of
voltage something similar to the
Milliken experiment so the child did the
sphere started to acquire charges and
the power of the laser is adjusted
automatically to compensate the electric
force that the sphere will under go
under this difference of potential so
here are the measurements so you can see
that this is the charging time so how
long the UV light is on and this is the
power of the laser needed to levitate
and you can see as UV light shines and
charges are created on the sphere the
power to levitate changes and of course
it's actually step exactly by the power
by the charge of the electron is a
discrete power change that correspond to
the charge of the electron and this is a
very high accuracy measurement of the
electron charge using optical imitators
now let's talk about optical tweezers
the term optical tweezers have this
coined by art himself and he has been
rewarded for the Nobel Prize for this
work so what is optical tweezers so a
laser here that goes to high numerical
aperture microscope objective focus the
light very tightly just not too far from
the objective and what happened is that
if we look
here at the zoom of this location at the
center here the minimum size of the beam
the waste of the beam the highest power
is in the middle here then there is a
gradient in the transverse direction
that any laser have it has more power
near the center of the beam than on the
edges but now because of this very tight
focusing the there is a gradient of
power along the axis of the beam so now
from the center here to going forward
there is a very big gradient of power
and what is the impact of that so we
have learned from previous slides that a
sphere is attracted towards the region
of high power so the sphere will
experience a force that's called a
gradient force that is not forward but
is backward so it's the sphere wants to
go back to the center of the laser and
if you have a sufficient focusing then
this the gradient force will exceed the
scattering force that is always there
and produce an attract small sphere
towards the center of the beam but not
exactly at the center there is a little
bit offset which is a maximum gradient
of light so the sphere will set off just
before the focus so in the single beam
you can track that you can trap a small
very cold transparent particle so let's
see it in operation so here we have an
optical imitator which will be used just
to bring the spheres next to the
tweezers on top you have the optical
tweezers so the sphere is at the bottom
of the tank you turn the laser on so the
tweezer here as it's a fixed power very
high intensity in it the focus point
then there is low intensity of levitator
it's not sufficient to levitate then we
increase the power of the levitator
the particle goes up and then is trapped
so a particle let's do it again
so the when the particle
lift is become trapped all of a sudden
in this location just after the focus so
that's the way in optical tweezers works
so let's now talk about some of the
Bulge goal application that art himself
measure so in 1987 art and Joe digits is
a technical assistant set up a
microscope to trap bacteria using 11.06
micron neodymium YAG laser so he started
with non living organisms and something
that doesn't have the shape of a sphere
so here I'm gonna show a video where
they took himself where you can see this
irregular particle being moved by an
optical tweezer and you can see
obviously that is not circular but it's
going to be manipulated by the optical
tweezers so the laser is that's one
micron so we cannot see it's not visible
but when it's turned on it moves this
small object here so it shows that you
don't need a sphere to use optical
tweezers to exert force on objects then
he it turns its attention to living
organisms so here's a Paramecium a
Paramecium is a single-cell organism it
is it is between 50 and 330 microns so
it's fairly big it has internal
component called organelles and they
range from a few microns to a few tens
of microns
here's a video that art took where it
trapped one of the organelles I want to
attract your attention here to the white
dot which is a an organelle and he's
going to trap them let's trap the
organelle twice so let's look at the
video so this organelle
it's trapped and a Paramecium will move
and then when it you're gonna eat the
wall its exit the trap and it's gonna be
trapped again anybody it's the wall
it's leave the trap again and now let's
look at what happens to a tobacco mosaic
virus a tobacco mosaic virus it's very
long so it's very different from a
sphere so I want to attract your
attention here this rectangle so the
tobacco mosaic virus is freeze moving
around there's gonna be trapped so now
it's trap doesn't move and then it's
turn in the inwards and because it's
trapped using by the end of the virus
because the end of the virus refract
light more and the optical tweezer is
stronger and now I decided to trap
tomato zoom in and we can listen to him
describing what is doing this is 1988
may not I don't know the power may not
be high enough or he's too active here
let me put up I'll give you well this is
about the maximum power
let me sit here I'm moving him now I got
a reference to movement right here you
can see our movie so now let's talk
about a few different applications so
molecular motors are biological
molecules molecular machines that are
the essential agent of movement in
living organism so here's example of the
keynesian the keynesian is a molecular
motor that can carry a load here a bead
has been attached to a Kinnison any
Kinnison is on a microtubule so the
keynesian want to transport that bead
and that bead is being trap and an
optical tweezer and this optical tweezer
is soft in a sense that it traps the
beat but not too strongly so the bead is
kind of free to move a little bit and as
it moves the it chain it deflects the B
is the beam of the tweezer so it can be
detected where the bead is in the
tweezer and if we look now at
measurements those are three different
measurements the step size here this is
a function of time of the position of
the other bead and you can see the bead
move and by step size of eight
nanometers so the bead is kind of the
keynesian is kind of walking along the
microtubules it's making eight nanometer
step stop for a while another let me
just step and and so on so now let's
look now something a little bit more
advanced which is the measurement of the
DNA on DNA templates so a DNA template
is attached to one bead which is in a
trap then the RNA polymerase is attached
and not a beat also in a trap one of the
trap is soft so it let the bead moves
the other one is strong the video
doesn't move much
and in the what we're going to observe
here is that the NRA Paulina Ramirez is
transcribing the DNA and we're gonna see
a video that is at 30 times the speed of
the two beats moving from a single DNA
and single RNA polymerase in action so
the beat is moving as you can see and
what bring them together is the RNA
polymerase transcription so now if we
look at the measurements of this
distance between the beats this is a
measurement that is about 1200 second so
we can zoom on it because there's a very
high resolution by a factor of 10 so we
see how yeah sometimes there's no motion
sometimes there's motion and if we zoom
even further we can see that now they
have steps of 3.4 Armstrong so to
perform Armstrong is only a few atoms
wide and this 3.4 instrum corresponds to
the distance between the nucleotides of
the DNA there are other application also
of this of tweezers here are some
biopolymers properties motion and forces
of linear and rotary molecular motors
molecular behaviors of nucleic acid
enzymes folding of structured nucleic
acid in proteins putting binding and
Michael manipulation a smaller object in
general and probably many more to come
there are also several companies selling
optical tweezers for different
application and different types of
tweezers art also wrote a book in 2006
published in 2006 I wrote it with the
help of his assistant of his wife Eileen
we present the fundamental of optical
trapping
I discusses different bicycle
applications of optical tweezers it's
also an historical account of the
development of optical trapping around
the world but also at the lab so here
are some other people closest to him
George edges with whom he worked for
many decades his wife for 64 years Allen
and some of his closest collaborators
over the years thank you
[Applause]
our next speaker is Donna Strickland
Donna is a Canadian experimental
physicist born in May 1959 in the City
of Guelph in southwestern Ontario she
received her bachelor's degree in
engineering physics from McMaster
University in Canada in 1981 and
obtained a PhD in optics from the
University of Rochester New York in 1999
where she and her doctoral supervisor
shirahama who developed the technique to
immensely amplify the intensity of short
laser pulses without destroying the
amplifying medium which was a severe
limitation at the time for the
achievable laser peak power this
so-called chirp pulse amplification
technique or CPA for short was described
in a three pages long scientific paper
published in 1985 Donna was only 26 at a
time and it was Donna Strickland's first
scientific publication and a subject of
her doctoral thesis her pulse
amplification revolutionized the field
of laser science and led to new advances
in many different fields including
medicine and the much-publicized eye
treatments Donna Strickland is
fascinated by lasers she has worked at
the laser division of the Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratory and at the
Princeton Advanced Technology Center for
photonics and up to electronics
materials in 1997 she joined the physics
department of the University of Waterloo
which is currently a professor leading
and
ultra fast laser groups that develops
high intensity laser systems for
nonlinear optics investigations
she was named the fellow of the optical
Society of America in 2008 and has
chaired several of its committees in
2013 she serves as its president please
join me in welcoming Donna Strickland on
stage to tell us about the developments
which led to this year's Nobel Prize
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you very much so I'm here to
tell you about how light interacts with
matter and then when the light gets very
intense it changes how it interacts with
matter I'll tell you that how we made an
intense laser and by the time we were
finished we had to rethink how intense
light interacted with matter so to start
we first have to go back and see how
does light interact with matter so
through the centuries scientists
wondered was light made up of particles
or was light made up of waves and it
went back and forth by the end of the
19th century scientists were pretty
firmly in the light is a wave category
so they were doing experiments with
different colors of light shining it on
material and watching electrons come off
the material now when they shun the red
light and I'm only going to describe
light that we see the longest wavelength
that we see with our eyes is red light
and wavelength is given by the distance
between the crests of the wave when they
Shawn red light on material electrons
did not come off when they tried to get
the light as bright as they could
electrons did not come off now when they
switch to green light which has a little
closer spacing of the crests electrons
came off but they came off with very low
speed they turned up the power of their
green light and more electrons came off
but always with very low speed and
finally when they tried violet light
which is the shortest wavelength that we
can see with our eyes so the shortest
distance between the crests the
electrons came off with higher speeds
and when they turned up the power more
electrons came off but always with those
same speeds now this flies in the face
of light being a wave if you can imagine
walking on a beach that's stony Beach
and if you just have small sea I know I
talk to a lot I don't need a mic
so when you walk on a beach and they're
stones and you just have little ripples
in the waves the stones don't even move
but if the waves are really crashing in
you will see those stones flying up the
beach and this is how waves would
usually move objects and so when we
turned up the power of the light we
certainly expected that the electrons
would fly off faster and yet they didn't
so it's this man here Albert Einstein
who probably thought of almost all of
physics all on his own what he won the
Nobel Prize for though was explaining
this effect and so we and optics are
pretty proud of the fact that this is
what he won the Nobel Prize for so what
he figured out was that light actually
is quantized in its energy there is a
minimum energy unit of light that we now
call the photon
it's a wave-like particle so what it
says though is that the total energy in
your light is then the energy of an
individual photon multiplied by the
number of photons the other thing that
he figured out then is that each photon
has an energy given by this wavelength
and so I'm going to do an analogy
because it's harder for us to feel the
energy of light so we'll use gravity
that we all know about standing on the
earth and that if we drop the ball from
higher up it would be faster when it hit
the ground the higher up you can drop it
so now a red photon is a small photon so
we're going to imagine playing
basketball with a child-size basketball
net and so if it's a red photon playing
basketball no matter how they try even
up on their tippy toes they cannot reach
that net to drop their electron through
and no matter how many of these
childlike photons there are the electron
is never going to get through that
basketball net now if you have a green
light that's like an adults playing with
a child-size basketball net and they can
actually dunk through but only barely
they're only stay
he's slightly taller than the basketball
net and so when they drop their ball
through ups we have to go back you can
only you have to drop your ball there
you go see so slow because it's just
slightly taller but the violet photon is
like your pro basketball player they're
the very Tolga people and so they're
well above the net and when they drop
their balls through the net
boom a lot more speed but it wouldn't
matter how many of these violet photons
they had they would all be dropping at
the same speed through the net just more
electrons coming off so usually when
people study the photoelectric effect
it's about quantum mechanics but that's
not what I want you to concentrate on
what it really told us about how light
interacts with matter is that it's
always one photon meeting up with one
atom at a time and they meet with each
other and if that photon has enough
energy more than the energy that the
atom is holding on to its electron it
can then send the electron on its way
and when there's more photons coming
they interact with more atoms but always
one photon meeting one atom at a time
and that's how we understood how light
interacted with matter through the
beginning of the 20th century and then
Along Came this woman Maria gave admire
the woman who won the second the second
woman to win a Nobel Prize
now I'm not going to talk about her
Nobel prize-winning work as I know
nothing about it
I'm going to tell you what she did for
her PhD in 1930 she published the paper
in 1931 and I cited that 1931 paper in
my own PhD so I don't know why she
thought about this right maybe she
brought her woman's way of looking at
science and thought why don't photons
get along why don't vote on want to work
together right because if two photons
would just come into that atom at one
time they would share their energy and
two little red photons would have the
same energy as one violet photon and
then the there we go
it would have an electron come through
with pretty high speed
this is what we now call multiphoton
ionization because there's more than one
photon in the interaction she didn't get
to call it that I don't know what she
called it it's all in German um so so
now we could understand that but nobody
had seen it
don't forget I'm Stein was actually
sitting there wondering why the
experimentalists were seen with Racine
Maria gave admirer I had nobody had seen
anything like this so I don't know what
made this woman think about it but in
fact nobody would see this effect for
another thirty years it was Peter
frankenz group at the University of
Michigan and I know I have a lot of
Michigan people in the audience that
were the first people to see a
multiphoton effect now they were doing
their experiment not with atoms that
would eject electrons but what happened
was that two red photons were
momentarily absorbed by an atom and then
when the atom wanted to let that energy
go it didn't let it go as two red
photons it let it go as one photon with
twice the energy so you'll see then that
the wavelength here is half well does
that looks less than half but whatever
we'll call it a half kind of everything
right anyway so this is now what we call
second harmonic generation all right
and we now see it more routinely
but this was something to see in 1961 so
then it begs the question why did it
take another 30 years to see what Maria
gave admirer had predicted back in 1931
what was special about 1961 well it's
already been mentioned in the previous
talk what was special about 1961 is that
in 1960 the laser was born so because
I'm giving a Nobel lecture I do want to
honor all of the people that have won
Nobel prizes for the laser bass off
Prokhorov in towns were really honored
for developing the maser the maser came
before the laser and the M is for
microwaves rather
light in lasers technologically it was
easier to make a maser than a laser and
so that was done in the 50s and they won
a Nobel Prize but it was the precursor
to the laser art shallow than one for
laser spectroscopy later on but he had a
lot to do with understanding how laser
works but I want to give credit to this
man Theodore Maiman working at Hughes
Aircraft he's the one who won the race
there was a race on at the end of the
50s and into 1960 who would be the
person who would first demonstrate the
laser and it's this man Ted Maimon so
1960 the laser was born and that's why
Peter Franklin's group could see this
non-linear optical effect now why is
that regular light as shining on me very
brightly here sunlight or what have you
is like this bulb right up here and in
normal light photons of every color is
coming off that's why it looks white
they go off in all directions and they
also don't talk to each other they all
go off whenever the heck they feel like
it no cooperation whatsoever that's not
how a laser works a laser as I'm using
right here I'm going to shine on the
wall over there you will see that the
light only goes in the one direction
where I shine it you don't see it going
over there because the light's not going
into your eyes the light's going over
there so we already have it concentrated
into one beam you'll also see that the
layers is just one color and in the case
of the laser pointer just green they
also the photons in the laser all talk
to each other and when one's out of
crest they're all at a crust and so each
of these photons are going together and
so they are making themselves to be a
giant wave and a giant wave means
there's the density of photons is
greater so let's go back and think about
the linear case here's what they saw
before 1960 just regular light photons
of every color just in case you don't
recognize them those are the photons
waving at you and because there was no
cooperation the density of the photons
is not very high so also when you maybe
take a lens and you think you're putting
sunlight down to a point I'll tell you
it's not going to a point
we can only focus light down to a
wavelength so the light that we see is
about a half a micron the laser eye
Bilt's one micron so we're gonna go with
that one micron is a thousandth of a
millimeter and so you can't focus your
beam any smaller than that to
concentrate your photons any better than
that but the size of an atom is much
much smaller now because I'm standing in
Sweden I'm going to tell you that the
dimension of an atom is an angstrom but
we're not really supposed to use that
unit anymore I'm sorry about that my
Swedish friends we have to say that it's
1/10 of a nanometer all right so this
atom is actually ten thousand times
smaller than you can focus the light so
when you blow up that atom because of
the concentration of photons you know
you're lucky to have one atom meet one
Photon
there's really almost no chance of two
photons finding one atom at the very
same time but not true with a laser
light the laser light have all these
single colored photons happily shaking
together I don't know if mine are
shaking together but they should be
shaking together and so they pack in a
lot tighter and so you have some chance
of seeing two photons in the volume of
the atom at the same time I want to
credit Nicholas Bloomberg and the person
who won the Nobel Prize for nonlinear
optics I'm also going to tell you that
it would took a long time for me to
realize there was a difference in multi
photon physics and nonlinear optics
because I was at a conference
celebrating 50 years of nonlinear optics
and I'll just tell you the people that
study molecules and atoms those are the
atomic physics types they say when they
watch in the atom that they're doing
multi photon physics those of us who
actually study light coming out we're
doing nonlinear optics but to me it was
a very subtle difference so this man
wanted for nonlinear optics so here we
go we now have a chance of two photons
so this gets me to my PhD sherrard gave
me a paper written by Stephen Harris of
Stanford University and he had this idea
that lasers were sort of stuck in the
visible to the infrared but we might
want this wonderful type of radiation in
high-energy photons past the violet
ultraviolet
maybe even out to the extreme
ultraviolet so for that we can't just do
second harmonic or even third harmonic
he had come up with theoretically ways
to maybe have fifteen photons be grabbed
by one atom and release a photon that's
got fifteen times the energy so George
said you know do you want to do that
just think about this paper and see what
you want to do for your PhD so I came up
with a way to maybe be in twice ionized
nickel I would be able to absorb nine
photons so that was supposed to be my
thesis never got to it anyway
that's why I needed a high intensity
laser and so I lay there itself was not
going to get nine photons squeezed in
turn atom we needed an intense laser so
how did we do it so first I want to go
back to this laser that I have in my
hand the power of this laser is about 1
milliwatt or a thousandth of a watt I
can make it a pulse one second long
pulse by stopping it opening it up and
shutting it one second later now in that
pulse of light then because powers
energy per unit time if my time unit is
1 second that's 1 milli Joule of energy
now I can also shine that on my hand and
it doesn't hurt at all
I won't shine it in your eyes but I'm
gonna put it in my hand and tell you
that that millijoules hitting my hand
every second doesn't hurt at all and yet
my paper that was only three pages long
and got me this Nobel Prize only had one
milli Joule of energy created it's also
all the energy you need to slice your
eyeball up it's all the energy you need
to cut glass and yet it doesn't hurt my
hand at all and so what's the difference
well if I had shown that one second
pulse of light out to where the moon is
and I have no idea where the moon is but
and and I couldn't do it anyway it would
be the beginning part of the pulse would
actually be this is always the one that
oh there we go the front part of the
pulse would actually be 2/3 of the way
to the moon before the end of the
would leave the laser that's how fast
light travels and so now in our
one-second pulse we have one millijoules
of energy in this one-second long pulse
of light now what did the Franken group
have in order to see that very first
multiphoton effect they had light that
was one millisecond long so that's a
thousand times shorter still 300
kilometer long line of light I will tell
you they had more than a millage all
they had a Joule so they had a thousand
times shorter and a thousand times more
energy and then with that million fold
they were to see the odd time an atom
grab two photons at once the laser that
we built in Rochester though was shorter
than that we squeezed it down some more
and in fact we squeezed it down so that
one milli Joule of energy was in one
picosecond or just a third of a
millimeter so all of the many photons
that would have stretched two-thirds of
the way to the moon were squeezed down
till they were just a third of the
millimeter we packed those photons in so
I know that my supervisor and colleague
will be coming up here and telling you
all the amazing things this laser has
done for us I'm sure even some of them
are gonna be he's gonna talk about
things going on in space but I'm gonna
bring us back to earth I'm gonna bring
us to Rochester New York in the United
States where I did my PhD at the
Institute of optics at the University of
Rochester and I did my research here at
the laboratory for laser energetics and
there I am back in the day now inside
this laboratory for laser energetics was
this absolutely beautiful dye laser it
was red and green and as I said it just
seemed like a Christmas tree to me and I
wanted to work with Gerard and this
wonderful group it is a dye laser a dye
laser is a type of short pulse laser in
fact this laser the pulses were actually
ten times shorter than what I'm talking
about so only a thirtieth of a
millimetre long so we had short laser
pulses problem is dye lasers don't like
to grab their energy
and hang on to it so you can't get a big
energy dial user so you can have short
pulses but the reason that the
laboratory for laser energetics was
there was to study laser fusion and to
study laser fusion you need a big laser
and they had a big laser this was known
as the mega laser it was 24 beams and it
could produce a kilojoule of energy not
a millijoules a kilojoule that's a
million times more energy so in the
laser lab we had short pulses and we had
big energy lasers but we couldn't put
them together more than one problem one
the dye laser had red photons and this
one wants to amplify infrared photons so
they wouldn't have spoken to each other
but there was a bigger problem when
people tried to put slightly short
pulses even into these lasers what they
found was that the rod would actually
get drilled all the way through and you
were left with a very expensive piece of
glass that wasn't any good so that
didn't so they had a stop trying to put
short pulses down their laser rods
because these nonlinear optical effects
were happening inside the laser rods and
they were drilling holes all the way
through them so that was the conundrum
that we were in in the early 1980s and
then gerard had his beautiful idea so
there are no pictures because i hate
having my picture taken i've had to get
used to it since october seconds but
there are no pictures which are night
together so we were out a meeting a few
years back and took this picture so this
is a very simple beautiful idea this is
what we want here we want a lot of
energy we want it in a very short pulse
we just don't want that in our amplifier
so if we don't want that in our
amplifier what can we do just start with
a short pulse strive to the naked a long
pulse amplify it up and then about the
end compress it all the way back down
and here you have what I like to call a
laser hammer so now how did we actually
do it we're gonna go back to this lab
because this was the lab I now you'll
see I've changed the title of it even
though I'm showing you the very same
laser and so the green beam is actually
not a green laser this is the laser back
here it's infrared you can't see the
beam coming out of the laser because
is infrared and we can't see it neither
can the camera the kind of mirrors that
we use in a laser lab direct just the
color we want to direct and so this
green light bends at this mirror but the
infrared came on through it would have
gone to a beam dump to protect all of us
from I feeling the heat of that very
strong laser and so that laser had the
same wavelength as the big neodymium
glass amplifiers that we wanted to use
so that was the laser I was to use you
can also see there's simply no room in
the end for me there this was one packed
lab but they shoved me into that corner
where the infrared came out and there I
am in 1985 with up 1.4 kilometers of
optical fiber so why did we need this
fiber well there was one advantage of
it's not why we needed it because there
was no room for me here once we had the
light going down the fiber that fiber
then went through the air ducts down the
length of the laboratory for laser
energetics where I built the amplifier
at the other end of the building that
was one thing but two other reasons that
we needed this fiber is that the laser
that pumped the dye laser it was not as
short as we wanted and we needed more
colors I'm going to explain why we
needed more colors I don't have time to
tell you what nonlinear optical effect
made the colors you'll just have to
believe me that it did and then this is
the component though what we really
needed the fiber for this was our pulse
stretcher so first understand pulse
stretching we have to know why do we
need a lot of colors in order to make a
short pulse if you watch just one of
these colors and we can just do the red
one you see it goes along there a red
wave would go on forever now if you take
more colors and you say that you want
all of them to start here you will see
that each wavelength starts to come
apart you don't have to go very far
until summer Peaks when others are
troughs and so if one waves a peak and
the other waves of trough they cancel
each other out to be nothing and so the
more colors you can add in the quicker
you will get to where it's zero and so
the more colors you have the shorter
pulse you have so we created the colors
in the five
and now it's time to stretch it how does
that work
well in the way that light interacts
with matter I said that the red photons
have the least energy when they meet up
with their atoms they sort of shake
hands but then they say we have you know
have nothing in common off you go
so they actually run faster than the
green and by the time it's a blue photon
they're actually considering some time
do we or do we not want to interchange
your energy and it takes a little longer
for that blue one to the side now and
keep on going
so now if you go down fiber you will see
that the red ran the green walked and
the blue sort of crawled and if you go
down something like 1.4 kilometers of
fiber well the red ran the green and now
you have a long pulse so I want to
explain the name of chirped pulse
amplification a birds chirp is called a
chirp because the sound frequency
changes in time through the note that
he's making so you'll see that in the
way to get a long pulse is to have the
red frequencies out first
and then the green and then the blue so
through our laser pulse now the
frequency changes and that's called a
chirp it's called short pulse
amplification because this is an hour
stretch pulse that we want to amplify up
so how does the amplification work so
it's it's some material that has some
atoms and sitting there not doing
anything they have to be excited by some
kind of energy source the original
lasers and the laser that I used you
just use flash lamps you'll see that it
lets up most not all most of the atoms
and a good storage medium we'll hang on
to that energy and stay excited until a
photon decides to come by so then you
can have a photon come along and meet up
with an atom and because we've excited
these atoms so they have the very same
energy as the photon that we're going to
try to amplify they meet each other and
the photon says to the atom I'll take
your energy with me and now we have two
photons and that atom lost its energy
those two photons are marching in step
together and they meet two more atoms
and now we have four photons and we've
given up two atoms of energy and
by the end we'll have eight photons and
they've given up the app four more atoms
of energy now this is actually very
wasteful because you'll see that by the
end of it we've left most of the energy
there in the amplifier so that's a
complete waste and we don't want to do
that if it was a laser if we were
putting mirrors on either end and have
it go back and forth until we steal all
of that energy and this is then why we
have to keep building huge lasers if we
want a lot of energy the laser rod
itself determines the energy per unit
area that you can take and if you want
to grab it all you actually have to put
in almost that much energy to start so
snowplow through and take the energy so
each amplification gets a certain energy
per unit area if you want more energy
you must get make your beam bigger you
must make your amplifier bigger and you
plow through again the other thing I
want to point out that is that the laser
material decides what's the energy per
unit area but the nonlinear things that
can cause damage is the energy per unit
volume so once you know what laser
you're using that determines how much
you must stretch the pulse so that you
keep it below any kind of damage
threshold so that's why we would have to
chirp based on the type of laser that we
used so now that we're amplified up it's
just time to compress and so with a pair
of parallel gratings greetings are act
like prisms that send different colors
of light out to different angles and so
if you watch the path and you'll see the
red because it was stretched it's
further ahead than the green and the
Blues trailing that when it comes off
this grating them each goes in their own
angles but by the time the blue one has
managed to get to the grading the red
one had to travel all the way back here
and could get here so that when they all
leave the second grading they're all
going together and we've put all of the
photons back together in time and so we
have a short pulse so then it was just
time to measure it my colleague Steve
Williamson came into my lab with history
camera one night and together we
measured did I or did I not actually
have an intense short pulse and the
answer was yes so we were very
copy that night in 1985 so what did we
do with it well remember I wanted to
study well I want to study hermano
generation that proved too difficult so
we're going to go back to the idea of
multiphoton ionization and we thought
that we would just kick that electron
and give it so much energy that it would
be able to come out of this well that it
sits in in the atom and so all those
photons would come up and kick that
electron out that's what we were
expecting to see but that's not what we
saw we have made such an intense laser
that the photons were packed in there so
tight we no longer had to worry about
them being photons it was back to being
just one giant wave now although it's a
short pulse wave so each crest gets a
little bit more intense and a little bit
more intense and so what happens when
you have a giant wave is that it
interacts with the atom that was sitting
in its potential my head can be the
electron and it would the wave would
push it this way and then the wave would
push it that way and then it pushed it
more and it pushed it more and finally
pushed it so much that electron was
allowed to go out of the wealth but not
only does it go out of the well it goes
out of the well into this giant electric
force and it is like a cannon being shot
right out of there now can either leave
or in two femtoseconds that lights to
own back and it may be driven right back
to the ionic core it just depends and
I'm not here to tell you about what
happens oops let me show you did I show
you at least the electron right now no
there we go the electron at least went
out I'm gonna leave that to my PhD
supervisor colleague and friend Gerard
Murray to tell you about what we
understand now about the new standing
intense laser light interacting with
atoms and I will just thank all the
people I want to thank the people that
built the original cpa with me of course
yard but also steve williamson and
Marcel Bouvier who are here with me
today Gerard likes to tell people how I
said that CPA would not be a good PhD
project or thesis could not be my PhD
thesis I don't know why he tells the
story because I was right it could not
be I had to
to sign it's worth it which I did
multiphoton ionization and I want to
thank the gentleman that helped me with
that project as well and finally I would
like to thank the creative team at the
University of Waterloo for making these
wonderful slides for me thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
our next speaker is Professor Geronimo
who who's a French scientist and a
pioneer in the field of laser physics he
was born in June 1944 in Alda Havilah
in the French Alps a town probably best
known for hosting the 1992 Winter
Olympics at least until now Moreau
started his career in physics at the
University of Grenoble Alpha getting his
diploma in 1967 and moving on to first
Quebec and then Paris to work on his
doctoral thesis he received his
doctorate from Pierre and Marie Curie
University in Paris in 1973 Jacques who
spent a large part of his career in the
United States in particular at the
laboratory for laser energetics at the
University of Rochester New York where
one of his doctoral students as we just
heard was Donna Strickland together the
pair devised the chair pose
amplification technique which today is
at the core of most high-powered laser
facilities in the world in 1988 moo-hoo
joined the University of Michigan in Ann
Arbor where he founded the Center for
ultra-fast optical science he returned
to France in 2005 and became the
director of the laboratory of applied
optics at the campus of Ecole
Polytechnique in Palace or a post which
he held on to 2008 moo-hoo is a
visionary aiming to create lasers with
unprecedented power he initiated the
multi petawatt apollon laser project in
France and coordinates the large
European extreme light infrastructure le
that will host even more powerful lasers
in Romania Hungary and the Czech
Republic
he's currently also the fuel director of
Isis
the International Centre for cetera and
Excel what science and technology
established in France in 2011 - among
other things developed the field of
laser based particle physics
jacquimo who has been the recipient of
many prestigious prizes but i dare say
that this year's Nobel Prize must be the
icing on the cake with that I'd like to
invite professor moo-hoo to join me on
stage to give a talk staking out the
future of high intensity lasers
professor mu
well thank you very much for coming
friends colleagues former students and
so on well it's always a dangerous act
you know to act up behind Donna you know
[Laughter]
anyway I'm going to try Donna it's also
a pleasure because there is many many of
my students in the audience
students of co-worker and for me it's
very refreshing is like you know when
when we had our group meetings you know
at watch us still at Michigan and so on
anyway so I I'm going to tell you yes
yes okay so I'm going ready to to talk
about my patient my patient about
extreme light so Donna gave you all the
background how to build this high
intensity lasers and so on you don't
need much more than that okay and so but
I'm going to tell you what you can do
with that okay because it's true that
it's only only recently but we had this
phenomenal intensity available and so
there is many new discovery shall be
made okay so that's my patient all right
okay and so I can maybe act okay I can I
can i yeah so everything like Donna said
everything and started from with Ted
Memon you know in nineteen nineteen
sixty and I'm sorry
yes and this one thing you know which
really strikes me about about light it's
a variety of things we can do okay
and as after ash Kingdom sorry showed
but what you can do you know
first thing is maybe you can slow down
at homes and it's a very very
interesting phenomenon we have seen with
the tweezers and so on and this so
people you know used it intensively very
successfully and trying to really use
the light to decelerate atoms and right
leg to the field of quantum optics and
cold atoms and you have Steve Chu in the
first row here which got a Nobel Prize
with cohen-tannoudji and also will
Phillips and so but LEDs this this fact
but we cannot really slow down the atoms
to very very small times velocity very
important is another way to say that's
it's a way or so to make it atoms very
cold and which temperatures you know
which are I think the coldest
temperature we can produce now okay now
the other thing you can do and this is
what is exciting
okay you can do just the opposite you
can accelerate particles and and you can
accelerate particles like electrons for
instance to the speed of light or very
close to the speed of light
okay and and this led really to a new
field which we called collectivistic
optics
I will tell you why we call relativistic
optics in a minute we know that light is
relativistic of kafka definition almost
and and so that the fact that we can now
accelerate particles to the speed of
light then LED of course now to a
venomous field you know which deals with
Alex accelerator physics nuclear physics
cosmology non your QED general
relativity extra dimension physics you
name it
very large very large physic okay so I
don't have to go to talk about CPA we
heard Donna st. you know of course we
because we are going to need CPA of
course to of course to accelerate this
particle and so on so I so CPA you know
we stretch the pause we amplify we
compress it and it's and finally in
order to get there short pulses I like
to say one thing you know because it's a
very it was a completely novel concept
at the time and because everybody has
you seen was into dye lasers okay
especially the guys at the lab at that
time and and and here we come with with
Donna with solid-state lasers and so it
was it didn't grab the attention of many
people except I will say a couple of one
one for instant was Sunni Swanberg who
just visit in my lab because he had hint
that was very something special and also
I had the visit of people from the
Lawrence Livermore Laboratory Mike
Campbell and so on magazine in the
audience because he liked me they
understood immediately that it was
something important for
for power increasing the power of lasers
okay so now with this CPA technique what
is fascinating is you can really produce
very very high peak power and we are
going to use this high power I will show
you in a minute
but just to give you a sense the power
of the peak power okay the the light is
in a petal in now it's only paid at what
range okay which is about a thousand
times the total power of of the world
walk grid so global wind great okay but
of course for femtosecond you know 10-15
seconds but nevertheless it extremely
important and if you take now this power
you know bees petawatt power and you
focus it like Donna said over on a on a
spot size which is a weapon for bright
you cannot take off less than that so
typically on me micrometers or so then
you get a fabulous amount of energy
density on a very small spot and this
course you know lead is leading to
absolutely new application just to give
you an idea okay light like the first
picture showed and about ashing use
short using poor fascinated by you know
really deliver pressure and but one you
are talking about pressure light at a
petawatt level when you focus back on
those small spot size you can really
produce pressures which is correspond to
about ten millions FL tower on the top
of your finger
so it is the largest pressure that you
can produce enough is but with light
with photons this is amazing so now this
is really the evolutions of intensity as
a function of years okay
in 1960 from the 1960 where may man
invented the laser and the first five
tribe lesson let's first ten years a new
technique improved the power and cue
switching more locking and then the
intensity plateaued he plateaued because
like Donna said you know you are
damaging you if you go higher you are
damaging you you your laser inside you
know you you you damaged I'm putting
this nice big track you know in your
your solid-state amplifier and you of
course makes you advise you're very
unhappy right Donna and so anyway so in
order to prevent Donna making mistake I
said well if you know that's not the way
to do it let's do it this way
okay let's try to let's invent so CPA
okay so she wouldn't write damage word
anymore okay
so so we we did she build it and the CPA
and then we we cool really now we are
not limited by by the breakdowns of
material loss and but and we could
really climb up now the intensities and
now I mean since we 85 when we did it
the intensity have to say as increase
anonymously okay eight or nine orders of
magnitude okay and it going to go
further up okay with with lasers like
Apollo that is being built lasers which
which is part of the Eloi
infrastructures you know and Gary and
and home mania and and and crag and so
on
so he's going up and as we are going up
you know of course we are traversing new
regimes of physics so the first one you
know we and Donna said it you know we we
started to really observe multiphoton
ionization differently and so on and and
and and observe what she was saying I
know
and so we climbed up this this means as
we climb up the intensity then we go
into relativistic optics Y relativistic
optics because for the first times you
know when you have when you can see
something this means that you have been
you have electrons with which are
agitated and because they are agitated
they are really move producing light
which are coming and striking your eyes
okay so but in the case of when you are
passing 10 to be 18 watt per square
centimeter so then what happened is now
the electrons in your atoms move by a
large amount and move at the speed of
light so the electrons not to light but
the electrons are really moving at the
speed of light so so that's about two
very interesting regimes you know which
leads to a lot of fact and and so on so
now of course if you are pushing this is
what we are trying to do now if you are
pushing the intensity up you know like
we are trying to do it upon in the eye
and so on the end you go into the you
travel atavistic regime and this time it
is because not only the electrons don't
can be moved at the speed of light but
also the protons protons which are
massive they're 2,000 times the mass of
the electron so the massive but a 10 to
the 25 or so what Pascrell centimeters
they move
the speed of light and that's going to
be very important then finally if we
push even the intensity even higher and
I won't say exactly how we're going to
do that Jonathan wheeler indeed in the
audience and can we can talk about it
but so we go into this regime where
light interact with vacuum okay
like my friend position says we are
boiling the vacuum okay we are really
separating the particles real particles
and the article virtual particle in
vacuum and this is what we can do and at
this regime which is ten to the twenty
eight twenty to twenty nine what Pascal
Santa materials okay and basically what
we do is we materialize the value vacuum
okay anybody so moving right along okay
so now just one thing if we go back to
the regime's you know at ten to fourteen
and so on you know then we can really
use this femtosecond lasers so we don't
add for instance to to micro machines to
remove to a blade material very very
precisely the reason is femtosecond
laser are so good for that is because if
you are using for me number continues
laser and you're shining the continuous
lasers on the on the on a target then
you are going finally to heat to all
volumes over targets so you cannot
really micro machine with that now if
you are using pulses which are much
shorter nanosecond
me nano secondly nanosecond pulses which
is for us is infinity you know it's very
long but you do better
because of course the heat doesn't have
the time to pop again between between
before the blockages it's it's molten
and and then you have the femtosecond
laser where you come with a very very
short pulse and you deposit the energy
and the the temperature I mean hate
doesn't have the time to propagate and
you make this very nice holes and it's a
very very precise way to read oblate
materials and this gives you some idea
you know of what we could do what we can
do in fact we are easily now is really
what widely known was he highly done
everywhere and you can see that we can
really make holes and so on very
precisely
there is no collateral damage and no
one's very clean and very small okay you
see but we have feature size which is
less than a micrometers you know in in
size and no damages so of course now one
beautiful way to use this with this this
laser is to is to do I surgery because
after all eyes you know is some magical
tissue and also is not the kind of
things where you have to be accurate
with eyes and so we thought about that
in fact we thought because we had with
little mishap happening in my lab and
this is one of one of my students within
the audience you know got a line into
laser cutter laser in his eyes and and
immediately you know for me to to the
students you know to the hospital and
they made the met after largest we
also here on Kurt and and so honkers
look at the detail do eyes both are here
and say wow this is very strange
and yes you got hit by the laser but
it's strange
and so detail do you see what is strange
well it's strange because the damage on
your retina is perfect so that
immediately you know of course you know
we had the University of Michigan you
know excited about it they put some
money in it and and and then we add but
started the field of femtosecond laser
which is a very very important field ok
so this is just just to give you an idea
what we can do you know on on the on the
cornea we can use it all kinds of things
now we can on enough technology and so
it was very exciting
in fact so if you are I'm just show here
if you have 50 picosecond laser which is
long for us ok and if you have 310 toes
are gone you can you see we can really
create this flap you know very very
nicely you know and this is being done
you know now as I saw also a few few of
the largest here in the audience and
right so now I I had I had a movie
showing this creation of a flap but I
have to say that and some cup after some
comments people say well if you show
this this this movie maybe some people
are not going to stand it you know for
because it's so I'm I'm not going to
show it okay and I will save some time
but anyway if you want really to talk
about that here your stay
cellist at least real at least we a
specialist you know on this thing here
okay down let's go back to my to my my
roadmap here and so as I said you so we
were here for a short while and now we
are climbing up as I said we are in this
area right now and what's exciting here
you know one we are like this right yeah
when we when you are in this area of of
you know 10 to the 20 and 25 weeks ago
when you are shining the laser over a
really small size I mean sports spots
eyes like donna said wavelength of light
then you have producing with amongest
intensities and you are producing
particles you know of any kind of
particles any kind of radiations with
very large with energy okay very freely
okay it's amazing and so this we call a
universal source of eye energy particle
and radiations and this and this type of
course of work is being done at learned
you know not the one in Sweden
anyway and and if you are interested
people here okay so now what we are what
we want to do now is we are producing we
this was an idea from Tajima and Dowson
tashirojima a very good friend of mine
of a lot of people also and the idea is
this ID in 1979 he said well you know
looking at ducks or whatever on the lake
you know looking at surf surfer and so
on
say well maybe we should use the same
effect that is being used by surfer in
order really to get particles moving so
they they they really wrote this very
nice paper but of course is 1979
so it's before 1985 so I didn't know
about this effect you know and Toshi
didn't know about the CPA okay so but
fortunately we had scientists at an
array of Naval Research Lab we really
were able ready to solve the potential
to put the two concepts CPA and laser
Wakefield accelerations you know
together in order to accelerate
particles and this is what is going on
now in the many many laboratories in the
world you have lasers here and you shine
the laser on this gas jet and and you're
polishing the plasma you know which is a
plasma is a kind of a soup of electrons
and and and protons and so on and you
are creating this wave this plasma waves
where the electrons are going to be
trapped and dragged at the speed of
light you know by this wave okay so this
now it is really we were talking last
night with Olga this is ready is the
future for electron accelerations and
for is because we have example problems
in in high energy physics the other
problems because they have to build this
huge accelerators here you have the CERN
accelerator and see 27 kilometer in
confluence yeah you know and about 70
meters underground so it is really of
course it cost enormous amount of in
of of money and now because for the the
next step the next next Collider is
going to be even bigger okay and will
cost in an affordable amount of money so
really it is very important really to
come to come and and with the new
technology and you think that if you are
ready we placing the technology use
right now in this in this case for
instance which is using radiofrequency
microwave and so on where you have the
gradients is of the order of less than
100 meters Android sorry Android MeV
pair meters that's what john wiley webs
27 kilometer but if you now are using
this novel techniques so josh is Tajima
idea to accelerate particles then the
you could ready fit you know a CERN
principal okay turn on a football field
okay so this is pretty good okay but you
know of course we like with toshi to
look ahead all the time and so some
people you know in agencies difficulty
to see that you know and and but anyway
this way we are okay and so we like to
look ahead and so right now let me tell
you but we can produce now something
like devices GeV devices centimeter size
okay now we can produce up to 5 GeV but
5 GV is is something like 10 centimeter
nap okay and yes we could really maybe
put turn on the football field but could
we - but much better
than that and right now the reason is
yes yes we cool
in fact I'm not putting your leg here
okay I week already in fact next the
accelerator kind of TeV accelerator on
the fingertip and by by doing what okay
instead of using gas which has which has
a very low density of electrons then we
have to use will act like to use solid
solid and so you have six order of
magnitude larger amount of electrons
okay because we are working also with
gas at low low density gas and and then
but you say Wow but I mean now light
won't be able to propagate through the
solid at this very high intensity and so
so okay fine but if we can if we can
really develop high I intensity x-ray
now but is instead of busy working in a
visible work in the x-ray regime then
with the x-rays high intensity can
penetrate into into the salad and to
produce this Wakefield this is exactly
what we are doing right now you know it
might be at the ecole polytechnique and
in collaboration with of course with
Toshiba Jima Irvine and also with some
people from the Eli okay because I think
really this is really may be the future
trying to work with laser wakefield
accelerations in in the high-energy
x-ray regime so we we have we have ways
to do that I don't have the time to show
it but
it's really I think it there is really
new new Avenue to do that now yeah I
just took a quick reminder that the ISIS
twe phenomenal phenomenal facilities
which are being built by the European
Union and which are very in in Czech
Republic in anger and in Romania well
you have absolutely beautiful facilities
facility we are not well really doing
different friends don't do three times
or something of course and the the end
and it's absolutely fabulous to have in
few years you know we will have them
working and welcoming large amount of
users and so an Arai for instance is
very close to get to the 10th beta what
objective now now you know what is it's
a big application coming back to to
societal applications there's a very
important applications if you can
produce beams of particles let's suppose
that you can put we can really produce
beams of protons well you know protons
therapy per exam for cancer and so on is
really the the the really the therapy of
choice okay because the protons not like
other radiation of particles they don't
burn the tissue between bit between
really the the skin and the tumors you
can really address tumor ask almost you
know uniquely so you can deposit your
proton exactly in a tumor now also what
is nice about having a high intensity
lasers is you can make particles
these particles you know can be had your
nucleotides and and so on and you can
use them you know to implant these
particles into into the near the tumor
or in the tumor of the patient also you
can use these these I do isotopes and so
on but you know which in order to do all
kind of diagnostics and so on so this
this CPA I mean CPA high intensity or
extremely light in the extremely extreme
light intense intensity or lasers you
know are very very used but will be very
useful in in in in medical world now
just also another egg applications but
this is dreaming what I like to do in
anyway so I did that all my life and
when I made my living with that and so
anyway so just one one really big
problem we have and this also together
with Toshi while working on it and by
the way we're not working because it's
easy what's going to be working on it
because it's difficult okay and what we
want her to do is to transmute transmute
nuclear waste because we have all
nuclear energy it may be the best
candidate for the future but you are
still you are still you know left with a
lot of his junk dangerous junk and and
that's reason Toshi you invented the
terms now toilet science it's time to do
toilets and it's time to to clean up
what we have produced you know producing
energy and so on for our living and so
and so the idea now of course is
is we have to find ways okay to mitigate
you know this you can't waste in one way
will be maybe to transmute this this
this nuclear waste into a new new new
form of atoms which are not which don't
have this problem of radioactivity and
so what you have to do is to change the
making of the nucleus okay of so for me
now if you have a if you have a nucleus
items a okay and you have a isotope a
and which is maybe like active for a
long time so that attracted me example
of technician for instance and which can
be radioactive for hundred thousand of
years then if you can if you can hurry
large a a neutrons because now we have
freedom we we know that we can produce
any kind of particles you know including
neutrons we can produce neutrons you
know in in this in nucleus then you are
changing the isotope a B but this time
it can have ready now radioactivity time
wheel is of the order of seconds of
course this is most favorable case but
so we will I try to extend the concept
you know to to of course so nuclear
wastes which are really polluting our
life right now so and so by the way
sometimes you have a lucky and this
isotope B becomes isotope C and it's
it's stable so it doesn't emit anything
so in conclusion for me is extreme light
is capable of generating the largest
field the largest accelerations the
largest amperage
and the largest pressure just with
flight mazing and it carries the best
hope and opportunity for the future of
science and technology so thank you very
much and I would like to add that you
know we are doing this very rich field
right now
a field of extreme light but I think the
best is yet to come
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
so this concludes the physics lectures
for this year's Nobel Prize to 2018 I
would like to extend my profound thanks
again three eminent speakers dr. s ER
mwyn dr. Donna Strickland and dr. mu for
wonderful talks and having said that I
would finally like to invite on the Bell
laureates Donna Strickland and Yahoo to
come up on stage with me so that you may
congratulate them again to this year's
prize so please
[Applause]
[Music]